dépister identifier un cancer
précocement est souvent une question de
vie ou de mort particulièrement
lorsqu'il s'agit de cancer à tumeur
solide chez les jeunes à l'Hôpital de
Montréal pour enfants des chercheurs
travaillent à mettre au point une
technologie de pointe pour y parvenir
des biopsies liquides qui pourraient
remplacer les techniques de dépistage
classique
leur outil de travail une simple prise
de sang une fois prélevé le sang est
étudié en laboratoire pour tenter de
voir s'il contient des fragments même
infime de matériel génétique de l'ADN
qui proviendrait des toutes premières
cellules cancéreuses une information
précieuse pour les équipes médicales on
peut savoir quelle équipe de cancer on
peut savoir s'il est encore là et est-ce
qu'il répond bien au traitement en temps
réel
par rapport à des images qui peuvent
prendre du temps avant qu'une tumeur se
forme et grandisse
la difficulté chez l'enfant c'est que la
signature génétique de certains cancers
est souvent extrêmement faibles donc
très difficile à repérer dans le sang
mais les technologies sont plus en plus
raffinées même avec des petites
quantités de sang on a une telle
précision à l'heure actuelle avec les
instruments de collecte et d'analyses
qu'on peut le faire la biopsie liquide
présente également un autre avantage
important elle est pratiquement indolore
et ne présente aucun risque le petit
Brandon 5 ans à survécu un grave cancer
mais durant son traitement il a dû subir
de délicates et pénible interventions
chirurgicales des interventions qu'une
biopsie liquide lui aurait évité si dans
le futur les parents les enfants ils
peuvent éviter une sergie avant le vrai
traitement qui la majorité du temps ont
besoin d'affaires
ça va vraiment aider ces dernières
années différents types de biopsie
liquide dont démontré leur grande
efficacité chez les adultes
certaines ont été approuvées mais chez
les enfants tout reste à faire ou
presque mon échéancier c'est que dans
les deux ans on est assez de données
pour lancer un essai clinique avec des
compagnons nous ce qu'on veut c'est chez
les enfants que ce soit la norme
rappelons que le taux de mortalité des
tumeurs cancéreuses solides chez
l'enfant se situe entre 20 et 40%. et
que l'heure cellule cancéreuses ou pas
se multiplient plus rapidement que chez
l'adulte ici normand Grondin
Radio-Canada Montréal